he starred in Ben Hur the picture the
won more Oscars than any other film in
history on a more personal note I'd like
to say that I spilled a you can check up
by a cutting bi Friday I'd like to say
that I feel a special connection with
him that we both have made biblical
movies Ten Commandments he played Moses
who parted the Red Sea and of course I
was in Oh heavenly dog ladies and
gentlemen mr. Charlton Heston
if you like the movies you're probably
watching this right now along with about
a billion other people all around the
world we always try to give you a good
show and we always give you a hell of a
horse race well people want to know who
wins the Oscars but the real reason
these awards are so important that the
people who will make the movies no
kidding
is that this award means that the people
who do the same work you do like what
you did we never know how it's going to
turn out no not just the awards the show
every now and then somebody really
screws up I sure did a few years ago I
was presenting and when the show started
I was five miles away on a freeway
off-ramp with a flat tire howard koch
was the producer that here and he
grabbed the biggest star he could see
out in the audience that was Clint
Eastwood
he was just sitting down there watching
the show and Howard shoved him on stage
Clint did swell but his eyes were a
little narrower than usual Windham he
said to me afterwards I've only had
about five lines to speak in 12 features
and they picked me to talk
over the years there have been a lot of
moments worth remembering though some of
them surprising screwy sometimes
heart-touching I can remember when I was
a kid listening to the awards in the
radio and Gary Cooper won for sergeant
York that's a lot of Oscars of golf so
for our 60th anniversary we thought it
would be a good time do for all of us to
look back at some memorable moments if I
were to mention all those who've shown
me such wonderful generosity through
Gone with the Wind
I should have to entertain you with a
narration as long as Gone with the Wind
itself
hello gorgeous welcome the Academy
Awards or as as it's known at my house
Passover and the so always begins with a
man has a voice who sounds exactly like
this
good evening my pants are killing me as
you can see I did receive my Academy
booklet on how to dress like a serious
actress I would like to open by thanking
everybody's mother and father the voting
procedures work like this
all except Academy members would go to
nominations to the package of the
ordinar missing my brothers beat Academy
brand documentaries and short subjects
are the sole exceptions I alone will
choose those winners
first the technical awards for the
development and production of a
high-efficiency yellow flame Carbon
reducing artificial snow and ice with
anticipatory noise reduction in the
spectrum of the light which in turn
develops the kind of using I'm Steve
Martin I'm here to present the award for
a special visual effects
by and Audrey Hepburn in waitin to
cigars the time of confidence
the winner is in the our model do I get
an in
shall we continue if you really feel you
don't deserve an Academy Award
just give us away from your sleep
Katharine Hepburn and guess who's Robert
Robertson Wonka Gary Cooper
the baby's head babies without
very Wilder Houston barbecue paddy
Chayefsky the winner is George language
and the winner is Indiana doing the
color on this show tonight Ronald Regan
right here
thank anybody I didn't know I was quite
that good except that I want to say to
Cornelia Williams Hurlburt my first
piano teacher my manager and my dancing
teacher pink Johann Brahms the other
Strauss me Chester my entire life was
gonna thank all the little people and I
can't tell you how encouraging a thing
like this is but I just say what's in my
heart the bomb the bomb
he has no genitalia and he's holding a
sword there as many nuts and the Academy
as anywhere else
he's look very regretful II cannot
accept this variation
I think it is one hell of an honor and I
am thrilled
I love you old enough
a deer hunter
khatoun I thank you for this great gift
which lends me such a very splendid part
in this